[Music]
good afternoon everyone good conference
so far yeah thank you all for coming out
especially pretty late in the afternoon
on day two hopefully you've enjoyed
today's talks so we've got one more for
you here
this is IO 303 best practices for
migrating to cloud sequel for my sequel
so it's gonna be a my sequel focus to
talk my name is brett hesterberg I'm a
product manager here at Google working
on cloud sequel and I'm Gabi I'm a
developer advocate mostly working
database and storage and cloud sequel
and we're gonna obviously be talking
today about migration strategies going
from a my sequel server that you manage
yourself to cloud sequel and more than
just talking about it we're going to be
doing it or more directly Gabi's going
to be doing a live with an application
before we jump into the the subject
matter we'd love to learn a little bit
more about you by a show of hands how
many of you are developers good chunk of
the room here okay how about DevOps
engineers and DBAs database
administrators good handful there how
about Reluctant database administrators
Oh a even more and do we have any
managers in the audience good we got I
think we've got some overlap I was I was
certainly the fractions we're adding
past one there okay thanks for that
feedback a couple more questions
um just by show of hands how many of you
attended next last year okay a good
percentage and how many of you as of
this moment are managing a my sequel
server good check-in room great all
right well I think we've got a good
content for you the feedback certainly
helps us shape this as we go along let
me start with the big picture what are
we going to be not only talking about
today but also building today what you
see in this diagram is a my sequel
server that can be just about anywhere
in the world with a replication pairing
to a cloud sequel replica
we've got an application at the bottom
which is reading and writing to our
external my sequel server while the
cloud sequel replica is keeping up with
changes with rights updates inserts
being made to the external server what
we're going to be doing as part of our
application my grave migration is
essentially failing into cloud sequel
and you see that depicted in this
diagram where now we've changed some
things the replication direction has
changed so we have cloud sequel as our
primary instance and we have our
external my sequel server as our
replicas and we've repointed our
application or application is now both
reading and more importantly writing to
cloud sequel as the primary instance
from there of course we can configure
things in cloud sequel ask cause equal
to do tasks like high availability for
us which is also depicted in the diagram
so that's our big picture today what
we're doing this on is is the back of a
fairly new feature for us we're very
happy to formally announce external
server support for cloud sequel for my
sequel here at next this just went GA
last week so you'll see this in our
public documentation and for those of
you who currently use cloud sequel
you'll see a brand new button in your UI
in our cloud console which is
highlighted on this slide and it's
migrated data we're gonna be using the
UI today to migrate our database like
everything in cloud sequel if it's in
the UI it's also in the CLI and the API
so depending on what you like to use to
manage cloud sequel instances you'll be
able to to do exactly what we're doing
today again we'll just go ahead and use
the UI okay before we get too far Ian
I'm gonna talk just a little bit about
how cloud sequel fits into Google's
database portfolio overall we'll get
into it just a bit about what cloud
sequel is and it's not and then we'll go
to the heart of our subject matter which
is migration and we'll do a live
database migration today as you see on
this slide Google has a broad database
portfolio right right most on the slide
are our third party or partner offerings
that our database specific on Google
cloud Google cloud generally has a large
partner ecosystem the list of third
party databases you see here is not
comprehensive there are many other
offerings this is a selection
it gives you a feel for some of the
databases available as you look left
most on the slide to our in-memory
database category our cloud memory store
team very recently launched Redis
support into beta so if you do have
caching needs and you're interested in a
managed Redis we have that now in cloud
memory store just right of Center is our
relational portfolio in the database
portfolio and you see cloud spanner as
well as cloud sequel cloud spanner if
you haven't had a chance to go to any
talks about spanner at this conference I
encourage you to do so it's a great
product to learn about cloud sequel's
mission in the database portfolio is to
be compatible we are we are offering as
close to unmanaged my sequel and
Postgres as we possibly can so that if
your application works today with my
sequel or with no stress it will just
work with cloud sequel in addition to
the compatibility cloud sequel aims to
manage the mundane aspects of
administration associated with a my
sequel server or Postgres server and
we'll talk a little bit about those
mundane aspects as we get into the
presentation
Jim Kelton from decart Labs is a cloud
sequel user and I think Tim sums up
cloud sequel fairly well he's saying for
his team they choose to use cloud sequel
because it allows them to focus on other
things that allows them to focus on
things that have more value for their
business and their customers tim's
worrying a bit less about database
administration when i tend to think of
cloud sequel i tend to think of the
technology stack that goes into running
a database many of you raised your hands
when i asked are you managing my sequel
today so you know this stack or at least
some portion of the stack pretty well
the leftmost column in this stack is the
hardware cause this is racking and
stacking servers thinking about power
and cooling for the servers and data
center as you move to the left the next
stack is the operating system itself
keeping that operating system up-to-date
with patches move further right even
than that and now we finally get to the
database beyond installing the database
itself we've got to patch the database
make sure it's secure and do things like
taking regular backups for data
protection finally right most in this
on the diagram is where things get
interesting and we get into some
advanced functionality from using
replication for example for high
availability or read scale out and
thinking about things like how do we
determine if a primary instance is
unhealthy what should we do about
failover should it be a manual tasks and
automatic tasks all of this then gets
wrapped into monitoring where we want to
make sure we know what's going on with
our stack what cloud sequel aims to do
is take this set of technology the
technology required to run a database
and turn it into a single API call so
that as a DevOps engineer developer a
DBA with a single API call you can bring
up a very simple development development
database or a much more complex
production database with high
availability automatic failover read
scale out what is not shown in this
diagram is what backs the cloud sequel
service and jason from real massive
another cloud sequel user points this
out cloud sequel is backed by a 24 by 7
SRE team these are the folks who write
the automation and the monitoring to
keep cloud sequel fleet of databases
healthy and when needed they're the
folks who get on the keyboard and bring
an unhealthy database back to life
Jason's pointing out here that this is
one less thing for his team to worry
about so that they can focus their
attention again on other things that
they believe have more values with that
overview of cloud sequel in mind we'll
get into migration options if you are
running a my sequel server today and you
wish to migrate that server that my
sequel database to cloud sequel you have
essentially a simple option and a more
advanced option what I'll start by
saying is whenever possible take the
simple approach it works and it's
straightforward to operationally to
implement the simple approach is this I
have my running my sequel instance my
server that I'm running today and
managing myself I set it to read-only
mode my application now can no longer
write to the database the database data
itself is frozen in time I asked the
database to export that data or dump in
my sequel terminology so I get all the
data set which is currently frozen
and when I have that I take it and I
upload it to Google cloud storage for
example as a way to get it into Google
cloud then I ask how sequel import this
data set when cloud sequel is done I
repoint my application that cloud sequel
and begin accepting rights it's a very
simple approach there's one obvious
consequence of this approach right which
is downtime and potentially a lots of it
there are ways to reduce downtime and
where if you're thinking about a simple
approach an application that is
reasonably tolerant of downtime you can
minimize the amount of time you're down
by really focusing on how to optimize
the import time importing data into a
database can be very time consuming so
this is showing three general themes to
optimize and import let's start first
with optimizing your schema for import
here it's all about handling keys as a
starting point import your data without
secondary keys you can recreate indexes
after you've imported
second item here is import your data in
primary key order this has real
consequences when we're writing data or
importing into a database the second
theme you see here is optimize your
cloud sequel instance for import cloud
sequel can be scaled very small it can
also be scaled very large and what I'm
recommending here is think about
allocating CPUs and RAM and storage
performance to cloud sequel so that it
has the infrastructure the resources to
run fast during an import also note that
while I think scaling CPUs and RAM is
very straightforward more CPUs more RAM
equals generally more performance in
Google cloud reach high storage
performance to storage capacity so if
you want more eye ops more capacity is
how you get those I ops if you know you
have a 200 gigabyte database allocate
200 gigs or more of storage to that
instance so that you immediately get the
eye ops I say that because cloud sequel
has an option that allows you to tell
cloud sequel grow the disk on my behalf
and you can start an import of a 200
gigabyte database with a 10 gigabyte
disk cloud sequel will happily grow the
disk incrementally for us through the
import what you won't get is the
performance of the 200 gig disk until
you reach that capacity level and then
lastly in this theme turn off an
advanced feature like binary logging for
the import which has a write consequence
has right overhead associated with it
last thing here is know how to monitor
the import process cloud sequel comes
with a set of basic basic performance
metrics that we show in the cloud
console know how to look at those and
watch out for reads we're doing an
import we should be just mostly writing
if we're doing a lot of reads that
indicates the database is paging we're
exhausting our buffer and we're doing
we're making the database do a lot of
extra work during import so these three
themes these three ways to optimize your
import can reduce the amount of downtime
associated with our simple migration one
note here is that after import we can
undo some of these things so I asked you
to scale your instance large for the
import I'm not saying you have to keep
it there indefinitely that costs money
every month cause sequel allows you to
very easily to remove CPUs and remove
the remove ram so you don't have to keep
a large instance in the long term
scaling it large just for import can be
a very cost effective way to gain
performance after import you can turn on
binary logging binary logging cloud
sequel uses for some advanced features
like high availability point in time
recovery things that we think you should
use so go ahead and turn that on after
import and then of course we add your in
add your indexes back as needed we
talked about disabling some of that
before the import bring those back now
that you've got your data there okay
those are general import performance
optimization steps as a way to limit the
downtime associated with our simple
migration now many of you saw right
through the simple migration and said
that's great for some non-critical apps
I have what about my critical apps that
aren't very tolerant of downtime what do
I do and that's really the focus of our
talk today we'll go through it
conceptually and then we're gonna do it
all together live with an application
that the gabbie has written this diagram
shows how we're going to minimize
today with our live app migration you
have an application pointing at your
existing my sequel server it's doing
reads and writes it's a live application
we're going to tell that existing my
sequel server to an export of your data
to a dump of your data as it exists
right now
the database starts doing that export we
don't stop the database from accepting
new writes new writes are coming in
updates and inserts are coming in we get
the export out which is now a little bit
stale we send it off to Google Cloud
storage and we import it into cloud
sequel this process may take minutes if
you're really lucky hours which is
common maybe even days if you have a lot
of data so you now have a cloud sequel
instance that has a data set that's
stale it doesn't have any of the updates
inserts that have been going on while
we're doing this process the upside is
our app has been up the whole time our
users are still happy what we do here to
catch up the cloud sequel instance is
set up a replication relationship
between your existing my sequel server
and cloud sequel we've called this
external server replication where your
external server is still the primary
instance it's still accepting new reads
and new writes and that's the important
bit here is the new writes cloud sequel
once it begins to replicate from your
external server it's starting to catch
up now it's it says ok I'm four hours
behind I've got some work to do and it
begins to catch up all the while your
external my sequel server continues to
serve traffic so we've had no downtime
thus far once we know our cloud sequel
replica is in sync with our external my
sequel server the two have the same data
set the last transaction I wrote here to
my external server is now in cloud
sequel now we can make our failover now
we can make our move we set our external
server to read-only
we say freeze the data set as it is we
make sure that our cloud sequel replica
has that data and then we break the
replication connection
now we repoint our application to cloud
sequel and we tell cloud sequel become
the primary instance start accepting
rights you are now the primary instance
our application begins happily writing
again and we've migrated into cloud
sequel or failed over if you
to the cloud with minimal downtime the
key here is that this process minimizes
downtime for a database of essentially
any size what you saw here is we were
keeping our external my sequel server or
old primary up as long as we needed to
to make sure we could get the data to
cloud sequel and the cloud sequel could
catch up via replication this works on
large data sets as well as small data
sets to limit downtime so it's one thing
to talk about this but let's start to
see this in action Gaby has an
application based on a lamp stack so a
very common stack that we see folks
using this is a single VM that includes
the my sequel database Apache web server
PHP and we happen to be running what is
becoming a very popular WordPress site
so Gaby's wordpress website started
small she's now gotten a lot of
additional traffic and you'll see why
when you see this site she has decided
to scale she needs to take my sequel and
that that workload off of this server
and send it to cloud sequel so we've got
our current state here we are on a
single GCE VM one thing to note here is
that this could be physical Hardware
this could be a server somewhere in the
world this could be a VM in some other
cloud with a point here is that Gabby
has full control over the database in
this VM she desires to move to a world
where she's offloaded although my sequel
load to cloud sequel where her VM now is
simply a web server with a connection to
cloud sequel for its database needs and
we're gonna get into exactly how to do
this in fact we're gonna do it live on
this this URL sorry about that for there
and click if you wish to follow along if
you want to see for yourself what does
downtime look like what does this app
look like as we're doing this fire up
your mobile device
browse to this URL what you'll find is
gabby has created a wordpress site that
has the listings of every Google cloud
next 20 18 sessions so obviously it's a
hot site and it's now struggling under
its own load you can watch us do this
live we'd love to get your traffic as we
go along
make sure you see when the site is down
exactly for how long it's down and when
it comes back up Gabby just a moment
Thank You Brad
let me give the URL up on the screen
here
oops can you switch it back for a moment
okay
you can see okay so this is a wordpress
that I imported the data from all of the
Google cloud next sessions for now you
can just browse through it it's working
it's on a single VM on compute engine
and today we're gonna migrate that my
sequel server from the VM to the called
sequel for purpose of clarity I'm gonna
be calling primary the server on the VM
and replica the one that we're gonna be
setting up now so Brad showed you the
new menu on the sequel - dashboard on
the console so once you access as the
sequel menu you can see migrate data
here and as we said we're gonna be using
the UI to be doing this but you can also
use the API or the CLI once you start of
begin migration you need a couple data
and you need to have prepare your server
for this one of the things that we
require it's for you to have binary
logging on on your must on your primary
and I also have GT ID enabled so we know
which last transaction was executed on
the server wants to generate the dump
foreign port so I'm gonna create here
I'm gonna zoom in so name of the data
set I'm gonna put next 2018 migration
living so the IP address that I have for
that website is the same VM from that
that address is this one
yes I'm copying oh you also need to have
a replication user setup on your primary
server to have the permissions necessary
to copy all the data
in this case I created our application
user called replication and I'm gonna
click here so you don't see my password
once you setup that you need to make
sure that the database version that you
are using you we are supporting my
sequel five six and five seven for
migration so my in my case it's my
sequel five seven on the VM so I'm gonna
just keep it as it is and if you use
certificate certificate as for SSL and
TLS you can setup in here
another certificate in my case I'm not
using it also click on next
it's gonna ask you for the name of the
replica you'll be creating I'm gonna
keep the name that proposed to me it's
the same name as the primary that's with
code Seco a hurry to it another
important thing is if you know where
your server is it's ideal for you to get
a database server that's closer to it
same region or even the same zone if
possible in my case if I look on the
compute engine instance I am on US
central and my zone is F so the latest C
doesn't get through hi I'm gonna keep it
on the same job as perturbation - you
can scale up for it is import and I'm
gonna choose a two CPU if
seven-and-a-half gigabytes of RAM
the idea is ideal proportion is if you
have a 5 gigabyte set get at least
instance with at least 10 gigabytes so
you can load our in memory and don't
have any problems with that as I said
before you need to have GT ID and binary
logging enabled you need to generate a
file on my cycle dump using the Mexico
down command and once you've generated
that file you're gonna upload it to
Google Cloud storage on a bucket it's
the buckets private so you don't need to
worry about security and you just choose
which file it is
it's gonna be imported as I said before
this does have the informations DT ID
and binary logging that's gonna be used
for replication if you're gonna be
connecting to this database without a
called psycho proxy which it is or
binary application to be transpired
for connection they makes your
application think that the server is
local
you can also whitelist an IP address in
this case I'm going to whitelist IP
address of the VM that we were using so
you need to give a name in this case
it's application and I'm gonna use the
same ip address as the database because
they are on the same server so one point
here is that cloud sequel comes with a
built-in firewall what ya doing right
now is telling cloud sequels firewall
allow a connection from this particular
address which is her application server
if we don't do this cloud sequel's going
to block the network connection yeah you
could in theory Whiteley's I like the
addresses on internet we don't recommend
you to do that that's an official non
recommendation we don't recommend you to
do that but for this example here we're
just gonna white with the IP of the
application once you hit create what's
gonna happen is we're gonna start to
provision an IP address for this
instance that's being created this IP
address that's gonna be created here
it's not the IP address I'm gonna use to
connect to the instance it's the IP
address are gonna use to whitelist on
your primary server to your firewall to
allow the connection to the database so
you don't need to put all your server
through the whole internet to see so on
so that's created provision you'll be
able in here to use this IP address
whitelist on your server clicking on
next gives you more information about
promotion we'll skip that for now and
just create it because this may take a
while depending on your load on how big
it is your day
I already baked replicas on on the side
so we're going to be connecting here to
first to the local server and I want to
show you how many posts we have in here
and compared to the replicas so in here
I have I have 456 posts and if
replication is working it should have
the same amount so let me connect here
and the IP address is
so
456 but you're like is the replication
really working you know we should find
out we should find out soon I wait to
find out it's less equator than you post
I will create a new post here
welcome to IO 303 on next
it was successfully created so if you go
to the page you see that scene there and
let's see the count again so here on the
localhost
we have 457 so it did add a new post and
on the replication also 457 so
replication is working you could also
see use the my sequel own commands to
see where on the binary log EU are where
which was the last UT ID this is just a
simple approach because it shows a lot
of variables on the screen and sorry
so next next next step is to freeze the
rights on our primary server because at
some point either you stop the instance
and I will actually add all time and
since this is an application that's
mostly read-only it can just lock the
write and be able to go through the
migration to the new replicas and
promote it to primary what I'm gonna do
for us to have an idea of traffic here
I'm gonna simulate a bit of traffic and
to about a hundred requests per second
and then I'll do the the migration here
and that's a quick aside how many of you
are familiar with Google cloud shell
okay that's good we joked that it is
Google clouds best-kept secret it's a
it's a VMs provisioned for you
automatically you can use it to explore
your project or even do some development
work and Gaby you're using it it looked
like to run a load generator is that
right yes because they find I had an
experience while I was doing the load
out of my own machine and Google's
blocked me because I thought I was
spamming so no it's avoid that so
between your load generator and I'm sure
many of you are browsing the session
site that Gaby has built to find out
where you're going next tomorrow we've
got some load on our site yeah right now
I just locked the for the primary
database and it should be basically
reading but it's not gonna do anything
right so if I try to edit a post it's
just not gonna work
the next step for that is to edit your
connection string on your application if
you're using communities you can
redeploy or if you're using any
continued continuous deployment - you
just change environment variables and do
that I'm gonna go to a simple approach
here I'm gonna edit the file because
it's just a WordPress installation and I
do need to put again I'm gonna replace
the local host which it is again the
database that it is on the same VM with
the one that we are setting up here it's
not going to show anything but now it
should be pointing to the replica we
still have one step to do which it is to
promote the replica to primary so we can
have rights again on your database so
once once you go back to the sequel menu
and access your primary you know I call
primary here but like when you access
your instance you see here this button
promote replica and also click on there
it's gonna disable the read-only flag on
your database just to be to accept the
rights that it wasn't before and before
and just after you click here so right
now what's going on with the application
is anyone hitting it with their mobile
device is it up I was asking what's
going on the application right now yeah
it's working and I'm standing while now
it's doing the promotion I'm sending
more traffic to it to see if we get any
errors or if the caches any downtime so
let's see if they at some point here
it's gonna finish yeah so while Gaby's
doing the corrosion again I think a
couple key steps here one is we
validated that data on our former
primary server our lamp stat exactly
match that on our cloud sequel replica
we made sure that the two were in sync
Gaby did this by showing number of posts
with WordPress there are a good many
ways to do this if you have a very
active application you
to set your external my sequel server in
some read-only modes of the right stop
then you can begin the cut over at Gabby
used a sed command to substitute
essentially the IP address of the cloud
sequel instance in her WordPress config
file rather than localhost so the
application now begins to shift and
point to cloud sequel and then the key
step here was what cloud sequel calls a
promotion which is you as an
administrator telling cloud sequel I
want to take this read replica which is
read-only and promote it to become a
primary instance meaning accepting reads
and writes what cloud sequel knows from
that point forward is this instance is
no longer a follower of something else
this will accept writes and blaze its
own trail so to speak yes correct
and right now it's promoting and you can
see the applications with downtime right
now so if you try to access the
application right now it's having
problems accessing because it's not
finding the connection without a trace
and this is the cutover point I think
you're seeing it in the audience right
now the application is down so this is
when you would schedule the on the order
of one to three minutes of downtime for
the migration Gabby had shown you that
for the bulk of the process getting the
data to cloud sequel and setting up
replication your app is live you can do
these things during business hours when
you're ready to cut over meaning when
your application is most tolerant of
downtime then we want to wrap up with
these steps yes and just me Nina and the
key to any demo is that it ends up
working yeah that's the problem of those
generally a promotion and cause sequel
takes about one to two minutes as Gabby
mentioned we're doing some configuration
work in my sequel itself which takes a
bit of time and then we're doing some
configuration working cloud sequel to
essentially move this replica to a
full-blown primary instance one thing to
note here while we're watching the
promotion is that the external server
technology we've released allows for the
reverse replication to happen as well
meaning we
can as a cloud sequel primary server
replicate to your external server as
well so effectively you're able to fail
in the cloud sequel and fail back out in
case of a problem with this migration
path for example you may wish to read
promote your existing server back to
primary and this gives you essentially
an out when when you're going through
this process we think it's important to
note this because we want to make sure
that migration to cloud sequel is as
easy in as it is out cloud sequel is
compatible and open and we want to make
sure that you have as many on-ramps as
you do off ramps so to speak yeah we
have some unhappy app users right now
who were desperate to know about that
tomorrow yeah let's me try with the
other promotion here with the one that I
just created New York with you oh this
is the IP address I think what happened
I don't know what happened I don't know
let's see I'm gonna do the same side
command and I'm gonna change the
promotion here for the other IP address
okay and let's promote to them one that
we just created see if he goes
so we'll see if we get our promotion
complete here and if we don't obviously
we've got a bit more work to do yeah
you got your hundreds that's good
for the questions and we're happy to
take a few questions at this point of
the demo if you can come up to the mic
that's in the middle of the room just so
everybody in the room can hear and so
that we can make it worked and the other
one didn't would this one work
so now let's see with I'm sorry for
interrupting you so sorry let's just do
a final test here let's create another
added the post
I had a typo here ah next let's update
it and let's see if on the front yes it
the e is down again hi the way I
[Applause]
configure I have pre configure instance
before so because I didn't know how long
you would take to get ready and not make
everybody wait and then I used the one
that I already had created before to do
the promotion which it didn't work so
the one that I created live here was the
one that actually worked in the end okay
so with that Gabby then what we saw is
the final step a critical step is when
the applications down it's controllable
generally in time regardless of database
size and in this case we hung on tight
and it worked our application is back up
and running so thanks for the patience
there yeah thank you okay so to quickly
wrap up then and we appreciate the
questions along the way we've ended up
in a realized state for our application
where we've moved my sequel off of our
single VM we've taken the M out of our
lamp stack we've moved this load now to
cloud sequel our sites operational again
and that's really the motivation for
this new functionality and cloud sequel
is very much this kind of migration path
where as I mentioned you can do this in
each direction you can migrate off of
cloud sequel in this way as well few
next steps for you all as I mentioned at
the beginning use a simple approach for
migration whenever possible that will be
for non-critical applications that are
reasonably tolerant of downtime think
about reducing that downtime by
optimizing your import generally
optimizing your import whether you're
using the simple down time migration
scheme or the more
advanced low downtime migration that we
just demonstrated optimizing that import
will be wise in either case to get
started with cloud sequel if you're not
already using Google cloud I recommend
starting with a free trial you get 300
free trial dollars which can be used on
any product in GCP including cloud
sequel it's a great way to start to
learn GCP and cloud sequel as well a
couple presentation pics for you we're
on day two at the conference we've got
some I think great sessions tomorrow as
well these are ones that caught my eye
as well as Gaby's eye we have one about
reinventing databases for your journey
to the cloud I think those of you who
are interested in spanner and more
generally our database portfolio at
Google would enjoy this session for one
about kind of how to think like an SRE
how to use Google essary for
availability reliability scalability in
hybrid environments this one's really
appropriate especially where many of you
are contemplating migrations to Google
Cloud Google helped invent sre and I
think that session will have a lot to
share around how we think about these
things in cloud last one on the list a
tongue twister
computing with power not previously
possible with bigquery and compute
engine this one it really describes what
you can do at big scale in Google cloud
lots of CPUs and with an application
like bigquery with that on behalf of
Gabby I want to thank you all for
spending a chunk of your afternoon with
us and we'd love to open up to questions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]